this is my friend dr heather irobonda
she dances on tiktok she's an army
veteran and she's a board-certified ob
gyn right here in new york basically
she's better than i am in a lot of
things especially the dancing
today i wanted to take a look at a
really controversial episode of the good
doctor so i called my good friend to get
her perspective and boy i'm glad i did
these shows with the central lines put a
midline in bro
you have two rambunctious boys i know
it's like a cage mansion here
sean was your first year resident i have
two first-year residents but i don't
want to teach them they're very
distracting you have a dizygotic
dicorionic die amniotic pregnancy how
does he know that um he's a magician
that's a thing these shows don't make
any sense like number one he's a general
surgery number two he was like how far
away and was like those are
die amniotic die psychotic that he saw
all of them yeah like all those parts
without scanning without standing
without checking your pockets what if
it's a bicornuate uterus
what look at that look at that family
medicine hitting them with medical terms
honestly to know if it's like diametric
dizygotic like and depending on how far
along she is it may be hard her belly's
pretty big so it's harder sometimes to
know those things unless you are able to
see what we call like the chorion which
is like the separation between the two
sacks she has edema not surprising for
someone who's 26 weeks pregnant pretty
big belly for 26 weeks did you agree i
already did that
what was her bp is he going to
preeclampsia route i feel like he he
he's hinting to it because whenever i
feel like any of these shows if they say
edema yeah they're like a d when he's
rushing for the blood pressure they're
like what's your blood pressure like
honestly in terms of preeclampsia that
is not actually one of the criteria to
diagnose it it used to be visuals spots
and divisions blurry vision high blood
pressure so 140 over 90 or higher
headaches that don't go away with
tylenol or acetaminophen if you have
pain in your right upper quadrant so by
your liver there's also protein that
you'll see in the urine we have to check
your urine in order to know that so but
he's gonna know it magically right now i
know he's gonna be like preeclampsia bp
is no longer normal she's
hypertensive what does that mean dr
murray
is your vision blurred
a bit i'm tired
it sounds like preeclampsia
we got it
we need to start you on
anti-hypertensive meds but your edema
makes it difficult to place an iv so we
need to run a central line
these shows with essential lines put a
midline in bro oh man that got really
intense
really quickly since when do we expose
patients to jugular vein lines exactly
because do you know how much we're
exposing them to bacteria and they make
mistakes and you can
you can cut the wrong thing and cut a
carotid like oh good god and they were
talking about doing it um giving her
anti-hypertensives and i'm like i mean
you can do that but you can also give
some oral medications for it too and it
depends on how hypertensive she is and i
don't think the number was like through
the roof i mean i didn't see it i mean i
didn't see it but i don't feel it but no
show it out yeah we'll see and he has an
apple and you know what apples do doctor
jackson keep doctors keep doctors away
and why is he eating during a thorough
procedure and also why is he eating in a
patient's room
fetal heart rate's dropping
that's not how a fetal heart rate would
usually look if it was dropping i just
want to say that i've never seen it that
way either yeah if it was dropping you
would actually actually see it dropping
i feel like those were not fetal heart
rates that would be yeah they look legit
yeah and babies heart rates are way
faster did you have another birth
no any pregnancy miscarriage abortion
still birth
i had an abortion when i was 15.
eclampsia [ __ ] fetus is rh positive it's
not father is rh negative i do it
and with antibodies antibodies she could
only have if she had an earlier
pregnancy
my body is trying to kill one of my
babies wow don't they check this by 26
weeks we are definitely checking so part
of the initial prenatal visit we do a
whole bunch of lab work so we're
checking to see if there's like any
infectious disease you know to make sure
you're not anemic and we also check to
see the rh factor so rh positive or
negative because we're concerned about
things like this where if you are rh
negative and you do have antibodies we
can start monitoring way sooner than 26
weeks for this the only time that this
could happen is if she wasn't getting
prenatal care which does happen which
does happen yeah and that's why we push
patients to go earlier and start the
process earlier so we can be proactive
dr jackson what's our next step
oh what's happening what's going on here
is this pregnancy has twin the twin
transfusion syndrome they have the same
placenta and they're sharing blood flow
and so typically what happens is that
they need to actually ligate or
cauterize some of the vessels block some
of the vessels that are in between the
two so that it doesn't shunt blood to
one twin over the other because what we
usually see is one twin is thriving one
is bigger one is smaller why would they
do that for um rh incompatibility that's
why this is all very confusing because
usually it's not due to rhs yeah
usually this is just a whole thing
happening on its own so we went from
pre-eclampsia to our age
incompatibility
to twin twin transfusion syndrome it's
very confusing to me interesting let's
see where this goes one of the amniotic
sex ruptured the strong twins
doctor i need help i need a console i
just i have no idea why the enemy
hunting sucks
helping the weak we hurt the strong
c-section if we do a c-section to save
the strong baby there's a 90 chance that
weak baby will die but if we do an mu
infusion to save the week baby there's
an 85 chance that strong baby will die i
definitely would not recommend doing an
amnio infusion we wouldn't want to do it
in this case because it can increase the
risk of infection basically if the
amniotic sac already broke that means
there's a hole in it and that means that
all kinds of bacteria can come into it
so if we put more amniotic fluid in
we're just creating this like breeding
ground yep if there's a strong baby and
a weak baby it's pretty clear which one
we save survival of the fittest
sorry it's just
it's not really what we're about is it
as a civilization aren't the strong
morally obligated to help the weak this
got really deep i know is this gonna
turn political like what is about to
happen right now i mean i see where the
where the discussion's going we we were
faced with these types of things all the
time in medicine where it's like we're
picking like the lesser of two evils
we're trying to figure out what the best
mode of action is what do you do in a
situation where there's twins like that
one is threatened the one is not it's a
group decision and i mean ultimately
it's always the patient the mom dad
everybody who's involved decision about
it because it's a really big deal and so
a lot of times we have the discussion we
give people the options we give them the
risk associated with it all the data and
then they give us their answer delayed
interval delivery we induce labor
deliver the strong twin then stop the
labor to keep the weak twin in utero
until his lungs mature i don't know
anything about this i'm gonna ask you
something can you do
a c-section get one baby out and leave
the other baby in um not for a c-section
but i actually saw this one case in
residency that was cr like
the most crazy thing that i've ever seen
and it actually was a set of twins where
one twin delivered and it was maybe like
30 weeks or so and then they did a high
ligation of the umbilical cord for that
one and left the second twin in and that
one stayed in utero
and then they delivered that one
it was
like the craziest slash coolest thing
ever dr thiel i remember you did that
once she hears there's the slightest
chance of saving both babies she won't
listen to any alternatives statistically
it's a terrible option
but it is an option present all the
options yes and see she has to make the
choice no you can't seriously be asking
me this i know that this is something no
mother should ever have to decide good
statement what do you do if a patient
says what would you do if i was your
family member i i mean i usually give
them my honest answer but i always say
that like my family may be different
than yours my situation may be different
than yours but it's really hard because
you don't know where people's actual
values stand and you're only seeing them
in that one particular situation you're
seeing them in that one particular time
in their lives what about you i usually
give full-on as if i'm giving my
family's recommendation but then
afterwards say like that doesn't mean
you should do this
don't use that as the reason why you
should do it right unless i really feel
like for whatever reason they really
should be doing this or like avoiding
something exactly usually exactly it
depends on the decision because like
this one is hard yeah it's life or death
this is a card but for an amnio infusion
have you named them
dr allen
is that
typical people name babies
in utero yeah people name babies in
utero all the time no
no i can't do this
oh
you have to save both of them ob gyn is
so tough sometimes but i don't think
these are ob gyn doctors they're not
they're not but
it's very hard the reason why i did ob
gyn was very much self-serving because i
was like i don't like bad outcomes
that's not self-serving that's the
opposite of self-serving personally i
don't know how i would be if i saw like
so many like people dealing with really
really bad medical problems and so ob we
deliver babies all the time oh i see
what happens
you mean that like you're seeing mostly
healthy patients mostly healthy as
opposed to like i'm seeing pathologies
right got it okay makes sense and then
like even gyn sign it's usually like oh
you have a niche i can fix that oh
you're bleeding too much i can fix that
and you can prevent stuff exactly
squares cervical cancer hpv vaccines
yeah hpv vaccine scarcely word insert a
16 gauge iv
16 gauge that's thick
you need big you know b
so when you need to put that fluid in
you got to run it fast and they're
inducing a pregnancy here to be
delivered yeah and it's twins
[Music]
his lungs are also underdeveloped he
needs to be placed on a ventilator
she's having another contraction adding
tubulin and calcium channel bluff
am i gonna lose both of them
i
don't know good answer good answer
kenzie we need to do a c-section no no
if he comes out he'll die if he doesn't
you both will no 69 over 40. why would
she die well chad's a really low blood
pressure why is she well i think because
at this point now she's hypovolemic she
probably lost a lot of blood her uterus
is still distended because it has that
other baby in there
but then you know part of maybe the
placenta for the first baby is like you
know there may be an issue with that and
so she's bleeding if they don't
basically get everything out of the
uterus and let the uterus kind of clamp
down and stop bleeding they both are not
going to do much you know i had a scary
moment one time i delivered a baby
vaginal delivery it seemed like a
totally normal like nothing happened and
all of a sudden
i'm like doing my check
and i feel like something's not right
uh-oh and i didn't know what's going on
because i was like something just
doesn't feel right so i was like i think
we need to call the ob he's like no we
don't like no we really need to inverted
uterus oh man and he came in and you go
and it was the most painful most
excruciating thing i've ever witnessed
live have you have you had that oh yeah
yeah well i got called into a room once
do a quick vaginal exam and i'm like yep
that would be the endometrium so that's
the inner lining of the uterus that i'm
staring at as soon as i open her vagina
i tried to do it first and it wasn't
going in because it had contracted a
little bit so we had to give her
something
yeah relax yeah
yeah she was bleeding a lot and so we
had to give her something to relax it
and
back up
we're doing a c-section let's prep and
drape her no
i can't
hear this lady wait they're doing it
right there i've never seen an in-room
c-section have you yeah but usually the
patient's not look at me with us
anymore usually it's post-mortem oh okay
try it breathe
good
you're not gonna give her a drape
100 over 65.
contractions are stopping
i mean you're not out of the woods yet
no so the peaceful music shouldn't start
just yet not yet she's 26
hi
and the other baby too
[Music]
all right judge this does this look like
a 26 week preemie looks
pretty young also usually they don't
bring the baby to you yeah you go to the
nursery or nicu in this case
we got through one episode yay
all right guys to check out more
episodes of the good doctor reviews
click here to check that out as always
stay happy and healthy and follow dr
heather irobunda on her channels linking
down below tick-tock where you want them
ig and six times ign tick-tock both i'm
greedy
[Music]
you